[Applause]
I move around a lot so it's probably
better this way it's great to be in
Saskatoon I had never been to Saskatoon
before and I got this very strange
message from Troy who said you know we
want to organize an icon carving class
in Saskatoon and be honest with
everybody
I get those kinds of messages all the
time people who asked me and say oh we
wanted to organize this thing with this
event this workshop or whatever and most
of the time you know if people have good
intentions right so most of the time you
know it doesn't doesn't pan out and it's
it's not that easy to find people who
want to learn to carve icons it's a bit
of an esoteric art it's not that known
and so Troy he says we're going to have
this icon Carbon class would you come
and I said I usually I just say sure
organize it and calm and then usually I
never hear from the person again
but then he Detroit keeps writing me he
says well how many people would you like
you know and I said well if there's a
minimum of maybe seven people I remember
I forget what I said then I'll do it no
and then he said no but what's the
maximum you want maybe you know ten
people is a good number
you know maybe 12 would be max he says
well I don't think we'll be able to do
under 15 and then maybe would have kids
there so we I'm thinking about 20 yes
who are these people so it's been it's
been a joy really it's been a joy
tomorrow's our last day it's been a joy
to be here and to discover these these
large Catholic families and they're
amazing kids who are able to spend from
eight to five you know working on an
icon and you know it's astounding to me
so it's it's very encouraging to me and
it gives me hope to find this community
and so I guess that's what I then I
wanted to kind of offer back maybe or to
talk about is to talk
about hope and to show some glimmers of
hope for those of us who love the
Christian tradition for those of us who
love the beauty which has been developed
in the Christian story and have sadly
seen our world move away from it have
sadly seen our world embrace a almost
cult of ugliness and so but there is
this glimmer of hope that you've seen in
the past few years and so that is what I
wanted to talk about this is Jonathan
Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
so if you look at this screen the first
image that I am presenting to you is in
1931 Stalin finally had enough power to
destroy the largest church in Russia
Christ saviors Cathedral and he blew it
up and so this is a picture of the
actual explosion and fire due to Stalin
destroying the the Cathedral they
estimate that the Communists destroyed
about thirty thousand churches during
their time burnt bullet blown up turned
into stables turned into whatever
decimation of an ancient tradition and
so in our world we have been lucky we've
had freedom and we haven't seen this
kind of persecution at least not you
know maybe since the French Revolution
we haven't seen that type of of
destruction but what we've been faced
with is rather a is rather a kind of
suicidal desire for ugliness and so
instead of having our church blown up
our churches blown up we are we are
given these churches I don't know I
don't even know where that is
and I don't think I didn't know we have
we have a church in Quebec and it was
this futuristic futuristic project of
this modern building and everybody was
happy about it but the people in the
city basically said you know what it
looks like a handbag and so and then
from then on this church has been known
as the handbag Church you go online on
Wikipedia if you want to know earlier
about this church right legalese suckish
the handbag church and so this is what
we've sadly been faced with and we've
seen it not only we've seen it within
Christian culture but obviously even
more we've seen it in the secular
culture where we've actually seen seen
an assault upon the entire tradition of
our Father
the entire tradition of Christianity I
don't want to dwell on on on the
ugliness but here of course is an image
by Francis Francis Bacon you know rep
representing the Pope as as was a famous
painting of the Pope I think of by
Titian making him into a monster and
putting him in this space dead carcasses
and this is the miss artist Francis
Bacon is a great example it's a great
example of this lauding of decomposition
and this praise of death of ugliness and
also of shock value that's one of the
things that is the most difficult for
people to understand especially in when
we look at all the modern churches which
we're also modern in 1950 and now look
also dated in 2019 it's because we began
to a mistake the titillating feeling we
get when we see something we've never
seen before this kind of desire for
novelty and for surprise we've confused
that with with actual beauty and that's
why all these modern churches age so
badly just like shag carpeting or
anything that was very much in fashion
and that quickly went away from fashion
because it was appealing to that desire
for the new and if you look if you read
the Church Fathers you read the ascetic
fathers they actually describe this
passion and they link it to a sin they
would call it a Cydia and it was this
boredom this kind of desire to be
titillated this is this boredom with
what we have and the desire constant
desire for the new I mean the demon of
our world is basically a sadena
the demon of a Cydia and so we've had to
face that and then the final type of
yes we've had to face is just the
ugliness of the you know the this
ugliness the ugliness of the but now you
know strip mall highway with science
random whatever everybody trying to get
your attention to buy something and no
sense of proportional sense of beauty
but just really a kind of and you know
what it's so funny because we're so used
to be correct we're so used to it
anybody who for example has taken the
time to go to Europe to visit an old
city or to even go to the old part you
know of Montreal or Quebec City all of a
sudden you are surprised and you see
this harmony this organic harmony would
just coexist and this this this natural
beauty which is both planned both
organic both both hierarchical but also
very a little bit of camera but not
nothing like the kind of madness that we
have to face every day that we that has
become our landscape basically oh just
want to give one more example and then
within the church we've had we've had
these assaults and some of them are like
this this I'm sure the person who made
this image was well-intentioned
that it was not out of hostility to
Christ or hostility to the church but
dozen don't looking like superheroes
exactly exactly what it's supposed to
represent but even within who the
Christian tradition we've had hostile
images that are presented I want to show
you an image this is called Christ with
hangers and as you can see it's actually
right now presented in a church by an
artist called Beauty Bob and it's just
what it said that's what it is it's what
a prize you know in the contemporary art
competition to have Christ on the cross
rep made with with coat hangers you know
and there's a little pun
they're hanging on the cross it's
disturbing to the utmost extent to think
that this would win a prize of art and
then would be put into a church yeah
alright so I want to bring you back to
this image this image of this
destruction of the ego and the talk with
the talk that I gave today was was the
title was given by Troy because I was I
was not answering his emails and he said
I'm just gonna give him the title for
the talk and he said it would be duty
among the rooms I think was the title
and that really evoked for me the image
of this situation and as you know I came
into the Orthodox Church and so this is
what the Orthodox Church had to deal
with this is this attack this
desecration the near destruction but not
only destructed with infiltration of the
Orthodox Church that happened in the
time of communism but in that death in
that rubble in that moment of deep
despair
that's where also this feed of hope is
born that's also where all of a sudden
these little lights these little
flickers appear and because of the
because of the darkness because of the
because of the rubble those lights those
little seeds they seem so much brighter
at the same time and so in the the
effect at this time in around 1930 up to
about 1950s or 1960s there are almost no
artists Christian - ographers in Russia
or in Greece it was dead there was
almost nobody the only people who who
were able to keep let's say the
tradition of icon painting alive were
what we call the Old Believers they're
actually a systematic group that were
constantly hiding from the church and
hiding from the authorities but they
were able to somehow preserve this
tradition you know within this
this attack and so some of the
immigrants who left Russia during the
revolution and because of you should
ended up in France and among those
emigres is this new little bastion of
thought this new little bastion of of
creativity began to be born and among
those intellectuals a lot of the
Orthodox theologians we know today come
from that time of that Paris to call it
the Paris school and among those there
was a man named live Leonid who spent
ski and leonid who spent ski took it
upon himself to renew the art of
iconography and he they scoured old
books he tried to meet with with people
tried to find what he could the writings
that he could the counsel that he could
whatever it is that he could find to try
to reinvigorate this almost completely
abandoned forgotten art and so he he
cried how could he wasn't he didn't
completely know what he was doing he
wasn't even trained by a master he was
figuring it out and he wrote some books
books about interpreting the icon book
about the theology of the icon and
painted icons and he did that his whole
life and remained a rather poor
individual his entire life but there it
was there was that little seed that
little seed that it first looked like
nothing it looked like it looked like
this one man who here he is writing
these books here is in his garage in
France leaning over his his his his
table and painting these little icons
but what he would light would become
this raging fire and we're gonna see it
happen before you forget I said I'm
gonna show you tonight and so among
among those people there there was also
another priest his name his father
Gregory crude who also tried to find a
way to paint these icons once again and
interestingly interestingly enough
father
looked also as much look at the ancient
art of the church he also looked at
modern art as well so there's a little
bit of modern art in what he's doing but
trying to keep it very tightly held by
the tradition of the traditional canons
of the church so there's this
interesting thing that that's got to
happen you're gonna see it develop also
in Greece there was a sub a little ear
of whose fancy in Greece his name is
focus kurta glue and Fortis same thing
on his own alone with no one you know
was a secular artist he had learned to
paint in school there were no icons left
pretty much no icon painters left and he
on his own decided to start up and he
started you know with this style that
was a little more naturalistic and as he
moved on and he discovered and he and he
studied that he looked at the ancient
massive master she went towards this war
he erotic you could say or more kind of
abstract style and if you look at the
Nikon like this here you will find that
if you go to many Greek churches if you
go online if you look you'll find icons
paintings in this style today all the
time and this is all due to and so in
the West and in Russia and in Greece and
then there are a few others some in
Georgia some in Romania these little
seeds these one that's always this main
same story one man sometimes one woman
who for example I teach at a school of
iconography which was which was founded
by a woman named Tanya for prophecy and
this woman was a chemist in in Russia
and because she was a chemist she she
was hired by the Kremlin to restore
icons restore the ancient ones that they
had ripped out of the churches put in
museums but they were falling apart so
she was hired to to restore them so she
had to study them she had to cut them up
and look at the the different pigments
and look at all the different things and
so she discovered how
the ancient icons were painted and then
while she was being hired by the
communist government to to restore icons
she was secretly painting them and
secretly teaching others to do it as
well so they would in basements they
would meet you know in in a very in in
places where they wouldn't have the ears
of the government and they're you know
in the guise of her official role as a
restorer as a as someone who was at work
for the government then she was able to
light those little flames and so as we
come to the fall of the wall and the
let's say that the freeing of the
Eastern Bloc we hear and a lot of people
hear about this renewal of Orthodoxy
this renewal of Christianity in the East
in Russia Romania Serbia and the way
that it's portrayed for us in the media
here is usually that it's all political
it's all Putin it's all this this this
political ploy to control the people and
to make them do you know with what who
wants maybe I don't know despite that to
the last of my knowledge in terms of
counting since Putin has been in power
in Russia they have actually built
20,000 churches and so Stalin destroyed
30,000 Putin built 20 so he's not done
yet
maybe he'll he'll replace all the ones
that were destroyed by by solid but I
want to tell you a little story to maybe
help you understand how that little
flame of love of beauty and the love of
liturgical art can be rekindled there's
a church outside of Moscow Moscow it's
called the Church of the protection of
the mother of God in us in evil
it is a gigantic Church it's one of the
biggest churches in in Russia and inside
it it's covered in mosaics it's covered
in gold mosaics like in Venice gold
mosaics and figures everywhere the
entire church is covered I think it's
the second most covered Church in terms
of its interior of mosaics and the in
interestingly enough the model for their
christ is actually the image which comes
from Sicily from the the those churches
built with a mix of Romanesque and and
Byzantine style that we find in Sicily
so the the floors are all marble floors
in 12th century cosmati style you know
everywhere it's gold there are candle
ears everywhere
we show you some pictures of the dome
and some of the marble revetment there
is no single large donor for this church
they received donations from 800,000
people to build this church they did not
have enough money to hire all the
artisans or all the artists or all the
people they need to build a church until
the the entire church all the marble all
the mosaics were all done by volunteers
people would show up in the morning and
then there was one person who was hired
and who would give them the tasks of the
day and the whole thing was made by
volunteers they didn't have enough money
to buy the tesserae those little glass
tiles that you get in from Italy and
there which are quite expensive and so
they made their own and for the gold
Tesar a people would send their earrings
their rings their jewelry through the
mail to the church and they melted it
down and they built this church
and so that is miracle and that is
something which you can can't fake that
but you can't convince me that this is
this is the psyops it's an amazing
testimony to the faithful who have
awoken to their faith and awoke into the
beauty that is possible now to be honest
the Christians in Russia are still the
minority the Christians in Russia are
not the majority there's still a a
minority people who are baptized are
still minority people were married in
the church are still a minority but they
have the fire right they're the ones
with they're the ones we're moving
they're the ones who are making things
move because they have something to
something to fight for you have
something that has value you know
they're not just sunken in their
nihilism as so many of us are around us
today
it was both not very long ago I think it
was finished about four or five years
ago yeah I don't think it might not even
be totally finished like the outside you
might not be fully finished and so this
is one example but all over Eastern
Europe there are churches being built
these monuments crazy monuments this is
this is a church this is the Cathedral
in Montenegro and it is completely
traditional in its structure it has
beautiful ornamentation but the
architect created this hierarchy of
materials where he started out with
these very raw blocks of stone and then
as you ascend the church the work these
the stone work becomes finer and finer
until at the top you have all these very
little Psalms that are all you know
hand-carved and all done so it's it's an
amazing church I get to give you a sense
of the of the size
and all around the outside they have all
these that I'm just showing you that for
me oh the church they have all these
beautiful hard icons that are on the
outside because they're stone now they
can survive the outside so they have all
these in these kind of raw blocks of
stone you'll find all these different
without carved icons on the outside and
on the inside it's all once again gold
and and painted icons and chandeliers
it's a it's a stupendous thing I want to
show you a picture of the cathedral in
Bucharest maybe some of you have seen it
it's not finished yet but this is what
just what it looks like give you a bit
of a sense of what's going on here and
so this is something that is happening
it's happening now this is happening
right now is happening all over and that
little flame that was lit by those first
iconographer those first people who
rediscovered the Church of the Lord and
wrote about it talked about the sacred
meanings talked about these sacred
patterns that we find this relationship
between the liturgy and the architecture
and the icons and how it's this giant
dance this giant pattern puzzle that all
comes together and that you can't
separate it you can't pull it apart you
can't you can't completely separate the
architecture of the church from the
liturgy from the things that are
represented in the church it all goes
together like one giant cosmic dance and
so from that there is this whole
flowering of iconographer zuv painters
and there was that first generation that
i that i showed you who spent steam
command/ctrl glue and a few others in
Russia and in Greece and in a few other
countries and now we have entire schools
of icon paintings we have masters who
show the way and people follow them in
different directions and so there's a
variety of styles and a variety of
explorations happening but all really
tied into that traditional spirit and a
desire to revive this traditional art
so I'm going to show you a few examples
of these artists and then I'm going to
start to show you a bit of my work so
this is father Zenon so father Zenon he
is one of the visionaries of the Church
of the art right now he is a he's an
amazing artist in the industry sense he
can he said he's an amazing draftsman
he's a virtuoso
in terms of painting he's just an
amazing an amazing artist but what he's
doing is he is plunging into the entire
history of Christianity and so he is so
for example in this image you'll see a
more kind of traditional you know
Byzantine Russian image and then this
icon that he painted the other one of
Christ entering in Jerusalem is based on
Armenian art and so he goes into
Armenian art he went into Russian
Byzantine he went into medieval he
painted some churches that have
Romanesque style that are very simple
kind of like Spanish Romanesque so it's
very abstract and then he kept going and
going and going and he started to paint
in the 6th century encaustic and he
started to think you know in frescoes
that look almost as if they were in the
catacombs
and so he's plunging into the entire
history of art and just exploring like a
little child you know who's just
exploring it's like oh this that and
this and that and this and he does
everything which absolutely virtuosity
and working towards what I believe is to
be a synthetic language to work towards
a synthetic language of Christian art
which takes into consideration all the
best aspects of this iconographic style
as it presented itself all over the
world and trying to bring it together
and show the threads that connect
everything together so he's an amazing
he's an amazing artist I'm giving you
all these names and you can all look
them up you know on your own
afterwards he won one of one of the most
surprising revivals of the surgical art
has been in Georgia Georgia has a very
particular style a very kind of bold
style which looks a little bit like that
say early role early medieval art in
France or in Spain that it's very bold
and very abstract so there's been a
whole revival of painters and artists
here's a here's an example of a dome
mosaic and see you know I have not seen
as bold an image of Christ if you look
at just the expression on his face that
strength we're so afraid to show that
now like we're so afraid you want Jesus
to be nice
Jesus is nice yes yes he's nice but he's
also the Lord of all and the king of
kings and so to see to me to see that
face that has a certain severity and a
certain presence to me it that that
scene that gives me hope myself and one
of envy the that's it the the kernel of
this movement like I said it always
starts with one person and his name is
Tommy Ron good lives it's hard to go I
didn't write his name so go deeds he's
up and the same he had the same story as
so many he started by restoring icons
for the government and then slowly
falling in love with this language and
learning the the inner workings of the
language and coming to create a very
very beautiful style that joins the best
of visiting art with the the Georgian
art and amiran was was commissioned by
Pope Benedict to replace the icon not
made with hands because the the UH the
icon not made with hands that becomes so
covered and so dark that you can't see
the image anymore and it was always
taken out an Easter during the Easter
service and so the Pope Commission I'm
here on to make the icon which would
serve liturgically at that moment so
this this is
and so in Romania we have everything
from a an exploration of very deep
classicism and it's kind of virtuosic
luscious classicism that we see in some
artists this is father
Ilya Baba who and I'm gonna name Daniel
Nikolai here everything on that side and
then we also see certain strains that
actually kind of are exploring a little
bit of a modernist sense a little bit of
those modernist
let's say composition and certain
sensibility is which which are not as
traditional but are still interpreted
within the traditional frame and we did
the traditional let's say Canon
canonical world and so obviously these
these types of images will provoke
discussion will provoke a lot of people
some people are fine they go too far but
the discussion is a real live discussion
that's happening and people take sides
and people talk about it if you're
interested in this discussion I edit a
journal called the Orthodox arch there
know which is which is online and we
feature a lot of all these artists from
the most traditional to those that are
pushing the limits that are trying to
see how we can connect iconography to to
let's say more modern art and so that
kind of brings brings a story to - to me
the as just as this happened this kind
of let's say awakening out of the ruins
of the modern world and we see this
flowering now all over Eastern Europe my
little experience was something similar
I grew up I was a Christian I grew up a
Christian in an evangelical church and
obviously there's a very close there's a
poverty of art
the evangelical church that it it's
nothing it's everybody knows even even
evangelicals know that there's a
property of art the Imagi local church
and I went to school studied
contemporary art and I just couldn't get
it to work I just I was studying
contemporary I was doing really well in
school
I finished actually finished first in my
art program but I just couldn't get it
to work I couldn't I couldn't connect
being a Christian
making contemporary art which is always
so cynical so removed from what they're
doing you always in contemporary art
you're always making or comment on the
comment on a comment of something that's
not what I want I didn't even know what
I wanted yet I didn't even know what I
wanted but I had this yearning to to to
to somehow connect my faith with the art
that I was doing and it just wasn't
happening I spend my entire bachelor's
degree trying to do that trying to find
symbolic ways of representing different
stories for the Bible and trying to fit
them together and to create all these
images in and then it's very funny
because of the very last day of my
degree the the professor was kind of
supervising me they were giving us like
a final evaluation and she sat me down
and she said say you know Jonathan she
said don't worry you'll get your getting
all A's you know it's fine don't worry
but uh what are you doing here she said
you really don't you really don't belong
here and you should go to seminary or
something and and it's so funny because
I was you know 21 or whatever he just
rolled out my back I didn't I didn't
take it but she was right she was so
right she doesn't even know how right
she was she actually gave me the
greatest service by telling me that yeah
a little did she know that I would
really take her her her her
recommendation seriously and so uh
so having let's say struggle I decided
I'm gonna give up art just gonna I'm
gonna
I was married at that point you know I
found a job and I said I'm just gonna be
a regular person just nine-to-five just
kind of stroke and to the thrill part
out the window double yet because I just
can't I can't take this no more I
destroyed all my paintings close down my
workshop that was it and I remember it's
funny because my wife she just laughed
at me she's like yeah Jonathan whatever
you'll see you know for now that's what
happens and then almost immediately
strangely enough after I kind of did
that almost immediately I started to
discover this this tradition that we all
share this this this beautiful amazing
story of Christian art which developed
you know if you had gone into a church
in the year 1100 let's say she had gone
to a church in Spain or a church in
Syria Constantinople or Sicily you would
have seen pretty much the same thing
obviously there would have been
differences you know based on local
styles or local local saints or whatever
but you would have recognized price you
would have known recognizes mother you
would have recognized several of the
scenes that you were seeing because very
organically very naturally a whole
language of visual relationships
developed in the Christian story and and
there was a whether you can only call a
universal language of Christian art
Christian imagery and it's astounding
and so at that time I just I stumbled on
to this this medieval art looking at
these medieval images and I'm seeing
that wait a minute this is there's
something going on here first of all
visually and second of all all these
images are all talking to each other
there's this pattern between the
different images and there are these
there's these let's say these codes you
could call it kind of a sacred algebra
of imagery of things relating to each
other so it's basically a language and I
realize this is this is
like this is what this is what I've been
looking for all my time in university
and this is this is it this is what I
want and at first of course I was like
well too bad the Middle Ages have been
finished for a long time so I don't know
I'm not sure what to do with that maybe
I could make contemporary art with
medieval no that's not happening and so
and so that's when that's when I
discovered the icon and when I
discovered Liam in response to who I
talked to you about at the beginning
this Russian man who rediscovered the
icon who wrote about it who wrote about
its theology who wrote about its history
and who painted icons also and so
reading that book following some priests
who who were encouraging me in that
direction I discovered the the icon and
I discovered orthodoxy and I remember
when I discovered medieval art and
looking through all these paintings
looking to all these objects to not just
paintings but obviously the reliquary is
India you know the the jewelry the
everything about it was just so
beautiful
and the architecture I thought I had the
secret prayer and the secret prayer that
I could make that maybe one day I could
make the Church of Guillard but I was
very secret I didn't tell anybody
because who you know who makes the third
ago.i that doesn't happen today so and
so I'm not gonna tell you the whole
story of how it happened but that's
slowly that's where I ended up and so
here I am today strangely you know
making sacred art you know as a job and
and so I'm going to show you some of my
work and hopefully talk about it a
little bit and so when I when I had this
strange little prayer that I that I had
and I kind of secretly gasps God that I
would be able to make liturgical art I
also had a strange list that I had and I
had all these things that you know if I
could just make all these things if I
could make these images if I could make
a reliquary if I could make a crow
if I can make it and alter if I could
not get ahead all the things if I could
make those I could just make one of each
that's not to be amazing you know and so
what's interesting is that I'm almost
done with my list I think there's just a
few things I haven't I haven't made an
altar yet but I'm do making a Crozier
right now for the Arts of the Catholic
Archbishop of Montreal so that's gonna
go off my list I'm working on that now
and so slowly it's I'm working on my
list though so here this is an image of
those nono iconography this is the
baptism of Christ so needed for
theophany and so this is carved in wood
and this one is carbon stone so one of
the things that happened in this kind of
revival of liturgical art is that at
first it was painting it was the painted
icon is that the main art of the
Orthodox Church but then the second
generation or maybe the third generation
then it became carving and embroidery
and mosaics and all these secondary arts
you could say also started to to reify
so I'm like in the third generation of I
didn't have a teacher so in terms of
icon carving I'm the first generation
there was no that really weren't any the
people who were doing it professionally
at my in my when I started they were
also all self-taught and and so it's
like this this is there's a new new
beginning you could say so here are few
more icons so these lows are in so and
everybody you know everybody knows with
ends
so here I wanted to bring the two more
these are more kind of these are based
more on western types and so there's
Christ kind of represented as a Frankish
skin maybe you could say and then this
is the creation scene from the church in
palermo sicily so this is the mosaics
that is that is on in that church so I
also started to make miniatures that was
also a part of my my hope that I could
make you one day it makes it these are
pendants for priests so Steve you an
idea that's maybe about three inches
three inches that's hard those both
those are carved in boxwood
right so these are these are stone
carvings that have in them semi-precious
stones that are inserted as well and
then some gilded to go with them and
what's interesting about these images it
kind of shows you also the way that
tradition works because no one has ever
made a hit just like this there's never
been anybody who's made you know like
let's say marble or stone carvings and
semi-precious stone inserts with gilding
you know and then also the metal that's
just not it's not something that
happened but if you look at it maybe you
think right you could think I mean like
this is an impression that I get I think
like this would be a thousand years old
you wouldn't know but then no one has
ever made that so there's something
about a traditional view vision of the
world something about a traditional way
of engaging the world which unites the
president the past together you know and
so there's nothing nostalgic about these
images you know there's nothing
sentimental where I'm hoping for a time
passed these images are used in churches
by people they're afraid with their
their part of people's life or not not
for museums I don't want to make images
for galleries or museums I refuse to do
that I want to make images for people
who will use them in their prayer lives
who will give them to their priests to
their newly baptized you know nephew or
you know godson it's like that's that's
that's that's real art that's art that
actually exists in the world that isn't
just a fetishized
object of commercial exchange or
prestige so some of the things that I
wanted to make of course also were
liturgical objects and so this is a this
is an altar cross which was made with a
with a good friend of mine liturgical
designer and he also designs churches in
the u.s. you know here in the north so
it's interesting is here in the North
where all the churches in Quebec all our
churches are becoming whatever bars
condos who knows they're all being
gutted you know but
even even in the south of the US that's
not quite what's happening so my friend
who designs churches that's what he does
for a living he designs churches and he
built these churches in the u.s. he
built a Catholic Church brick Basilica
in Greenville South Carolina so you can
find it online it's quite beautiful so
gospel covers and I also had the chance
to have Catholic patrons who have asked
me to do some statuary so I don't make
statues for Orthodox patrons but when I
get a Catholic patron who wants me to
make some stature and quite happy and so
obviously diving into the medieval
imagery diving into the medieval
aesthetic but then also with the hint of
Byzantine thats a flair to what I'm
doing and so these these like this sack
you could never have existed it's not
there's nothing
thought copy of anything you know it's a
traditional image that is not a copy of
something
she's a here's a crucifix
and then there's like
so that is the little message that I
wanted to give everybody today hopefully
it is it is a small message of hope and
it is also I think it's a message to
remind us that it's us ready it's us
we're the ones there's no one else
there's no one else who are going to do
this if we want an awakening of beauty
if you want an awakening of a
remembering of all that our ancestors
gave us of all this amazing this amazing
language that was handed to us you know
over the centuries that said it's us and
all it takes is one strange Russian
emigre in Paris or some lady you know
who's a chemist in Moscow who just
starts to take it seriously and to teach
other people to do it and you know and
and and 30 years 20 years later it's a
blazing fire so so hopefully that was my
that hopefully I'm bringing you a bit of
a bit of hope for that so thank you very
much
[Applause]
okay so before I start and there's a
nice lady who came to see me and she was
very distraught by the fact that I spoke
of Putin in a certain manner and he
wanted to remind me that Putin is a very
ruthless politician - I completely agree
I do not want people to think that I
that I approve of his methods or of his
intentions and I mostly wanted to show
what had happened since the end of of a
communism and especially contrasted to
the fact that it is presented to us in
the media as only a a political play
whereas I do believe that there is some
of that happening but there's also these
beautiful authentic stories like the one
I told you about the church in the
neighborhood so hopefully that is clear
all right so some religious traditions
design the architecture to accommodate
their music which is chanting how much
is the acoustics a part of determining
the architectural designs your focus is
visual art it seems is there also a
musical revival that is influencing how
churches are now designed and so yes the
design of churches in the Middle Ages
were extremely influenced by acoustic
and that's something that is being
discovered even more now recent times
there have been some really fascinating
studies that may be a little bit out
there but but are fascinating to think
about where people have been comparing
the iconographic program of churches to
the architecture and so for example they
had certain domes you know that were
made in a certain manner and then if
certain poems were sung then the sound
would bounce off that particular dome
and would seem
emanate out of the image and so there's
this idea that somehow that representing
like it would represent angels or
something like that and so then this
this the singing of the choir would
resonate in a certain manner that it
felt like it was coming out of the of
the angels on the walls singing and so
this is a theory that has been proposed
recently and there's more study that is
being done on the relationship between
the acoustics the the architecture and
the iconographic program all working
together it is kind of you know this
kind of hole now in terms of designing a
church for acoustics I have a friend his
name is Andrew rule I mentioned him I
think during the the presentation and he
designs Orthodox churches he is also a
choir director a musician and one of the
things that he does is design his
churches for acoustics
it is part of the of the way that he
designs the church and luckily we have
an entire tradition it's not it's not
it's not it's not mystery you know the
the Basilica structure the apse the the
dome all of these all of these elements
of traditional Church architecture are
also even though they have a powerful
cosmic symbolism in terms of
representing the dome of heaven which
stand which is on earth they also
participate in the acoustics of the of
the church and to the answer is there a
musical revival in the Orthodox Church
there is it yeah there's a massive music
revival in Georgia Georgia enchants in
Russia all over even in the u.s. there
are some composers who who are composing
new Orthodox moosic who interpreting
Orthodox music and so it's a it's an
interesting yeah it's an interesting
time and for parishes music is that it's
the first reality you know in an
orthodox setting it's more important
than even the icons because it's
we kits all the time so to getting
getting the music right is they have
massive conferences in the US for choir
directors for you know composers to come
and and participate in this this this
trying to get the music right and what
does that mean in America like what in
what in North America which tradition
are we going to follow the Byzantine
tradition with all that chanting and or
the Russian tradition with four-part
harmony and so there's all this
discussions happening right now so how
did the artistic tradition first go off
the rails and what role did Leon
Battista Alberti play so my question is
I'm not sure well Alberti is the one who
develop perspective is that right
whoever wrote this question all right
okay yeah well you want me to make
enemies here okay I do I do think and so
many of you will not agree with me and
that is totally fine I do believe that
the artistic tradition began going off
the rails in the Renaissance I do not
believe that the Renaissance was a was
at its foundation a Christian movement I
believe that at its foundation it was a
revival of pagan thinking and a revival
of pagan imagery which now doesn't mean
that they weren't beautiful things that
were produced at the time and that
doesn't mean that everything that comes
out of the Renaissance is is bad but I
do believe that that's where things
started to slowly go wrong and then you
have this these these pendulum swings
that start to appear and so you have
this you have the Renaissance and this
crazy one-point perspective and then
right after you have mannerism
and a kind of excessive elongation of
the figure and the kind of weird
expressive movement then it goes to to
romanticism neoclassicism and so you
have these seasons this pendulum swings
and swings and then goes into modernism
and did you know from Abstract
Expressionism to to hardcore not linear
modernism and so I think that it's
that's sadly where it started and you
can see it it's not just a visual but
also that's the place where the
traditional this universal language of
signs or this universal language of ways
of representing scenes that had very
powerful symbolic meanings started to
break down as the artist wanted to show
their route Raza T wanted to show their
capacity to innovate and and and didn't
seem to understand the structures that
were there in the Middle Ages if you
look at our graph II in the Middle Ages
or in the you know all over all over the
Middle Ages the images speak to each
other the images refer to each other and
so certain signs that certain elements
which appear in one image will reappear
in another and then other elements will
come in this one and so you have this
discussion that's going on so the way
that it's represented is completely
creates this symphony you could call it
like a visual symphony and within the
church for example in a church the way
that the images would be represented
when they were painted was also related
to the actual space so certain images go
in a certain place and other images go
in another place it's not fixed it can
vary but there is that whole thinking of
how these images talk about the space so
that's something which started to become
more and more arbitrary as time went on
to a point
we just forgot what what these images
were or about and what was was part of
them so yeah
all right so if a person wanted to be
part of a reviving Christian art would
there be any other route other than
iconography itself is it really the
traditional beautiful language that can
transform any medium any type of art
okay so I believe that I believe there's
a I call it a hierarchy of art I think
that liturgical art is the route that is
it's the most important art because it
is the art which is made expressly in
the service of God which is made
explicit to serve the sacramental life
which is meant to hold the body and
blood of Christ which is meant so all
these objects that are made by us in
within the liturgical life I believe
that's the highest that's the highest
form of art because that's what's most
connected to our lives and then also
pointing towards the divine within that
is also this whole the whole eater
djegal life it's not just a painting
right it's also the yearly cycle of us
celebrating all these different feasts
of celebrating of celebrating the
Pentecost of celebrating or the
ascension of stuff all of this all goes
together so that exploring that
exploring all those relationships
exploring how they represent how they
manifest themselves in the visual realm
in the hymnography in also how they they
recast a lot of the patterns that are
already in Scripture I think that that
that's that is if you if you want to
revive Christian art in any way if you
want to write novels if you want to make
movie if you want to make comic books
that's where you need to go no matter
what it is you want to make if you don't
want to make the surgical art that's
fine but you need to know those stories
you need to know your Bible you need to
know the lives of the sanctuary to know
all those beautiful patterns so that
when you end
writing something you can write a story
that's not at all Christian no we were
talking about this yesterday who was
with no Toki and wrote this book Lord of
the Rings
there's nothing Christian about it just
doesn't talk about Jesus doesn't talk
about God but then every Christian reads
it and recognizes these patterns that
remind them of their Christian tradition
he has integrated those patterns so
deeply that he can write a fantastical
novel that has no characters that you
recognize but you recognize that way
more as a Christian story in parentheses
than going to see some you know horrible
Christian movie you know about I don't
know like some horrible moral tale about
that you go that you rented just bad
stuff okay and so that's it like we have
we have all these stories they're so
powerful and we've forgotten them so
diving into that is is is what I think
is the key all right so so what do you
consider to be your greatest achievement
in your life oh my goodness
horrible question can I answer that on
my deathbed I mean this is except for
having kids and my family I would say
that would be my greatest achievement in
my life but I mean I don't know it's a
very hard question to have I think that
I let's say this in terms of
professionally you could say the thing
that I'm the most joyful about is the
fact that I can do this
you know if you had asked me ten years
ago do you think you could make icons
and then make a living and support your
family I would have laughed in your face
because yeah in America like how is that
even possible
so I think that to me I would say that
that's the greatest blessing in my life
you know at this time is to have this
opportunity that has been kind of you
know presented to me that I can that I
can
in the world in this way so all right is
there something symbolic in the way
icons I this one has drawings on it
[Laughter]
is there something symbolic in the way
the icons hold their hands and
especially fingers spaces between
fingers and there's a drawing of a hand
at the word space that okay so there is
sometimes a symbolic meaning of in the
way that icons hold their hands not
always you know there is obviously if
you look at an icon of Christ often
you'll see him blessing with his right
hand you know and if you see often I
don't know if I don't know if we still
do that today but you know traditionally
then the priests would bless with the
same gesture that you would see in the
icons of Christ and so they are
different there are also different types
of blessings that you see in the in the
icons there are also there are also how
can I say this there are gestures of
supplication in icons too you see a
Saints who have their hands out like
this that suggested supplication if you
see a site that has their hands covered
it's a gesture of submission so you
often see that sometimes the Angels they
have all their hands covered and they're
kind of bowing and they're holding this
cloth so that's a gesture of submission
so there are all these little these
little symbolisms of how hands are held
all right and what is the deal with the
big circle or hundred people's heads the
halo
[Laughter]
okay I can answer that
so a the halo and halo is a it's a to
glory it's the glory of the of the
person being represented you know it's a
think of it as a circle of light or it's
what's it's the it's a visual sign you
know of the that person's holiness and
it didn't it came from pagan times it's
not a Christian invention the the Romans
represented halos around the Emperor's
to show exactly that to show their glory
this is the this is the Emperor and he's
a glorious person and then Christians
took that and there was some hesitation
for a while where they also had it for
Emperor's and saints and then finally
only for the Saints and so and so today
we only have halos for the Saints and so
you can think of it as they even as a
crown maybe you know something akin to a
crown this round golden thing that
surrounds the person's head and in
Christ halo we always place the cross
first to identify Chrysler you make sure
you don't confuse because obviously
Christ is different from all those other
people is not at the same level and so
to be able to recognize Christ for the
cross and his halo but also to remember
also to remind us of this idea that he's
the he's that middle he's in the center
and the cross is around him you know I
almost think of it as a you know like
the four directions of space with Christ
in the middle like a church that's a
cross and then
the middle under the altar you see
Christ in the dome you know in the
middle of the church in the middle of
that cross so it's kind of like the same
same idea right so how does one approach
the question of relativity in the idea
of beauty
how can one be sure of an objective
standard by which to measure beauty
well beauty like beauty has a objective
aspect and it also has a subjective
aspect okay let's say it this way to the
extent that we are in communion together
that subjective aspect is going to
mitigate itself and move towards the
objective aspect and if we are in a
society that is fragmented and is
fragmenting then the opposite will
happen we will become more more capable
of seeing the communal beauty you could
call it or the beauty that binds us
together and we'll only be able to
notice the beauty that titillates our
individual passions you could say and so
that's one answer the second answer is
that we are human beings are beings of
pattern that's how we exist in the world
we are pattern recognizing machines
everything we know everything we see we
are always seeing patterns will you see
meaning that's what we are we are
meaning creatures that's what makes us
in the image of God that's what makes us
different from the animals is that we
are always seeing patterns and so the
objective aspect the beauty is that the
the aspect of beauty which will be
manifesting the cosmic patterns the same
types of patterns that actually appear
and we can notice
in nature that we can notice in these
geometric patterns that we see in a
flower that we see in in that in in
nature a flower has a as a pattern we
can see it and then we can extract from
that the the pure pattern you could say
because the path the flower also has a
chaotic aspect to it right as a has an
individual particularly particular to it
so we could abstract that out and then
you can put it up and we can make a same
glass as s and we can say that's a
flower but that's not the same flower
right that's a it's a purified flower
and so it participates in the same types
of pattern that we find in nature but it
is it is refined and we've pointed to
the pattern and that's how people
recognize beauty
so it's variable it's not just one thing
there's not just one thing that's
beautiful but our capacity to to to
engage in patterns and to see patterns
and to be attracted to patterns is the
objective you could say aspect of beauty
so hopefully that helps
all right so what would you say to a
parish that is planning to build but is
experiencing tension between those who
would spend more on a building and those
who would rather see those funds given
to the poor so that's a that's a that's
a that's a real tension you know and
it's a tension that's been there from
the beginning in there forever
there are homily by st. John Chrysostom
where he complains about churches that
are too fancy and he and he says that we
should be you know who should be giving
to the poor then he ends the homily by
saying you know but if there's gold in
the end like there's gold leftover then
obviously that just be on the altar it's
like so it's he doesn't totally say it's
horrible what he's saying you know you
should there's that there's a story I
was telling at the table relating to
this there's a story of Justinian
Emperor Justinian who when he built
Hagia Sophia there's this legend that he
wanted to build I think it's the actual
doors of the church or or the doors of
the of the altar area something like
that he wanted to build up out of gold
completely out of gold and the patriarch
said ok you know you can you can build
that out of gold but if there's only one
beggar left in Constantinople after
you've done that then you have to answer
for that out Judgment Day and so the
legend says that you just made them out
of silver so but that tension is real
and you know being a Christian is a
complicated thing it's not easy to be a
Christian you know we we need to we need
to be attentive to the poor as Christ
asked us to and to show love to those
who who need that attention but we also
are liturgical beings and we also
glorify God by our hands by the things
we do and we also show God's glory to
the world by doing that and for some
reason you know our our ancestors you
know in Quebec you go up the coast of
guest feed you go up this coast and
there all these villages one after the
other
and you know these villages must have
had like thousand people 500 people who
knows but every single village has a
more and more beautiful Church as you go
I thought it felt like it was like this
competition about building beautiful
churches so our ancestors these poor
these poor you know farmers and and then
woodsman who my answers who were on the
coast of guest say who who barely had
anything they still wanted to build a
beautiful temple for God despite all
their difficulty despite you know having
14 kids that was still one of their
priorities and so we need to do it all
that's that's the problem we just need
to do both I don't know how to help the
actual practical part of that but I
think we need to do both okay tell me
when you're tired of this because I
could just keep going here okay you
showed an example of icons with the
modern influence what does modern mean
in art is it the comment on a comment on
the comment that you mentioned so when I
use the word modern I meant it most at
the beginning of the century there was a
movement that was really a break of of a
kind of neoclassicism and late
romanticism now the reason why some
artists are looking to that period is
because although there was a destructive
aspect to their work there was also a
desire to show spiritual aspects in
their work as well so there was this
kind of desire to to kind of call forth
that something spiritual in their
paintings so you have artists like
Kandinsky or Moldavia and and several
other artists that's what they wanted
because the art had become just this
strange photographic representation when
we tried to represent visual reality to
the best that we could and it was this
feeling event but there's something
missing
missing and so some iconographer x' have
the sense that if you look into
modernism there are little strands of
things you can pick in that you can take
and that you can maybe use to to
integrate into icons but it has to be
subtle those that do it in extreme way
they'll just be so just be rejected it's
just not it's not gonna hold but there's
that little discussion happening all
right I think I think we probably done
huh everybody are you good yeah I think
it's it up what is it like 9:30 I think
we're doing I think we're done I think
yeah all right everybody thank you so
much
[Applause]